Franziska it--some bagger lives where
other people go on vacation
she's an 18 year old student who wants
to become a teacher
garmisch-partenkirchen at the foot of
the Chooch pizza is popular with
tourists from all over the world it
hosts about a million every year is busy
any time of year summer or winter
there's so much to do I was born here
and I want to stay here all my life
because it's so beautiful and because
traditions are maintained when it comes
to food for instance now for my first
recommendation a traditional Bavarian
vice Wars breakfast which will have a
severe Dean feller wolf the fresh vice
roster or white sausages served in hot
water make a hearty meal there are lots
of techniques for eating a sausage but
we advise forests like this you cut them
open then push them out of their skins
with a knife they're eaten with soft
pretzels and if you want sweet mustard a
breakfast like this can easily last
until noon it's brunch Bavarian style
and of course you have to drink a beer
with it
amply fortified it's time for a bit of
activity sledding just above
garmisch-partenkirchen
yes mine it's like here's my second tip
sledding even if we don't have a lot of
snow you can always find a place to go
sledding my favorite place is below the
Olympic ski jump let's go
here there are kilometer long sled runs
to suit every taste that was a fairly
easy descent that's why we have the
traditional sled race for anyone who
wants more action
and now it's a tradition in gommage pot
incursion the race has been held every
January since 1970 the participants are
all amateurs
well a bunch of lunatics I wouldn't dare
do it it's much too fast look at that
speed it's insane these sleds do up to
90 kilometers an hour while several
thousand spectators cheer them on
and now for my third tip something
special playing an alpine horn Elizabeth
I'm I'm I'm sure he's ready to help she
offers courses in playing the Alpine
horn all year long it's a bit of
folklore in Bavaria you always have to
keep the air flowing keep your abdomen
tight and don't cut off suddenly
that's very unmusical now let's produce
a tone
it's pretty strenuous you have to keep
your abdominal muscles and your lips
tight the vibration of your lips
generates the sound
I take care see you again in
garmisch-partenkirchen today